c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui vit à
100 à l'heure entre son travail de
pharmaciens les terrains de football
mustapha larbaoui 56 ans mène une double
vie professionnelle de passion qui
s'emboîtent dans un emploi du temps
surchargé président du club de l'étoile
sportive l'homme né à versailles gère
aussi depuis 2007 la pharmacie
principale située rue jean jaurès à trac
c'est le football qui man cette
pharmacie lorsque j'ai repris le club de
foot
il m'avait semblé que il serait bon de
rester sur le secteur parce que j'ai
besoin d'être présents physiquement sur
les terrains donc j'ai pu allier les
deux quand j'avais une heure par ci par
là je l'a consacré au foot
allez on dit bonjour détection il ya la
télé là tout le monde aujourd'hui ça va
c'est bien ça et faire vous savez faire
pardon alors faites le hockey
entraînements matchs rencontre avec les
éducateurs le dirigeant pas 7 jours sur
7 sur les terrains de football depuis sa
prise de fonction en 2003 pas de place
pour les loisirs le week end le samedi
c'est les plateaux le matin l'engagement
des enfants est totale elles font dans
l' envie de gagner lé envie d'être
perfectible mais on parle envie de
performer
donc on a forcément des échos le samedi
après midi c'est pareil le dimanche la
journée que les vétérans le matin non
non moi je suis connecté
permanence c'est facile il ya des outils
pour ça mais d'abord je me déplace
beaucoup surtout à l'extérieur
et puis à prendre les connecter le
portable les messages les résultats je
les ai tout de suite
mustapha larbaoui a également créé en
2015 une section de football féminin qui
compte aujourd'hui 92 en dehors des
terrains l'académie a vu le jour ce
renforcement scolaire permet à des
jeunes du club en cm2 d'avoir des cours
de mathématiques et de français
trois classes de 15 élèves se sont
ouvertes depuis deux ans moi je suis
qu'un acteur dans la chaîne éducative où
j'ai vraiment le sentiment que pour pas
employer de grandmont outrance mais de
véritables valeurs d'un président de
club qui fait passer des messages
structural qui organise mais en même
temps qu'ils vivent au quotidien son
planning devrait s'alléger dans les
prochaines semaines après 14 années
passées à la tête du club mustapha a
décidé de raccrocher les crampons ce
mois ci j'ai souhaité m'arrêter cette
année c'est parce que j'ai toujours eu
cette l'idée qu' il fallait jamais assez
très longtemps surtout trop longtemps
quand on est dans un tourbillon comme
celui que je vis professionnels
associatifs les personnels on se rend
compte que les choses vont vite ce que
j'aime et en même temps il ya des choses
qu'on risquerait de laisser passer et
je voudrais surtout pas passer à côté de
certaines choses importantes mustapha
larfaoui restera président d'honneur de
trappes est responsable de sa pharmacie
avant d'envisager d'autres projets qui
le mèneront peut-être vingt autres
tourbillon la politique